Яків Смолій, який очолив Нацбанк у березні 2018 року
після відставки Валерії Гонтарєвої,
написав президенту заяву про звільнення через систематичний політичний тиск,
який на нього здійснюється
За словами Смолія, своєю відставкою він прагне застерегти від подальших спроб
підірвати інституційні основи центрального банку в Україні.
Заява спричинила ефект бомби.
Для більшості оглядачів це була цілковита несподіванка.
За нею послідував шквал заяв, від МВФ до послів "великої сімки".
Усі міжнародні спостерігачі висловили глибоку стурбованість.
Не стали винятком і німецькі радники уряду України.
Я вважаю, що це дуже погана новина з двох причин.
По-перше, в останні роки Національний банк під керівництвом пана Смолія
робив добру роботу. Обмінний курс гривні відносно стабільний,
облікова ставка на рекордно низькому рівні.
Інфляція низька.
У зв'язку з пандемією коронавірусу, яка важко вразила усі країни, не лише Україну,
жодної паніки у банківському секторі не спостерігається.
Все і далі працює.
Усе це, думаю, результат роботи Якова Смолія і його команди.
Тому дуже шкода, що відбулася ця неочікувана відставка, з одного боку.
Але ще більше мене непокоїть політичний тиск, про який він казав
і який змусив його відмовитись від цієї роботи.
На думку оглядачів, у відносинах України з інвесторами заява Смолія -
це скандал колосального масштабу.
За законом і міжнародними канонами, Нацбанк має бути захищеним від політичного тиску.
Але ще більше, ніж сам факт передчасного уходу глави НБУ -
до кінця його каденції у 2025 році,
економістів вразили
додаткові обставини цієї події.
Лише кілька тижнів тому Україна підписала меморандум з Міжнародним валютним фондом.
МВФ схвалив надання допомоги обсягом 5 мільярдів доларів.
Україна також отримала допомогу від ЄС та від Світового банку.
І одразу після цього у ключовій для співпраці з МВФ інституції – Нацбанку
відбувається кадрова зміна на найвищому рівні.
Таке не могли сприйняти позитивно.
У день відставки Смолія Україна провела розміщення єврооблігацій.
Транзакцію довелося терміново загальмувати.
Міністерство фінансів України, яке паралельно проводило розміщення облігацій
на фінансових ринках, зупинило цей процес.
Із вказівкою на "нові обставини".
Треба було реагувати.
Інакше була б небезпека, що після оголошення відставки ціна бондів впаде
і інвестори втратять багато грошей.
І наступного разу вони двічі подумають, перш ніж позичати Україні гроші.
Тому потрібно було зупинити цей процес.
І Мінфін зробив цілком правильно.
Невідомо, як буде розвиватися подальша співпраця з МВФ
та іншими міжнародними фінансовими установами.
Песимістичні прогнози нині переважають.
У зв'язку з падінням довіри до України як партнера може відбутися відтік інвесторів.
Дехто прогнозує гіперінфляцію гривні.
На це накладається ще й гострий економічний спад,
до якого призводить пандемія коронавірусу.
Смолія німецькі експерти дуже хвалять.
Але закликають керівництво України якнайшвидше знайти професійного менеджера.
який буде так само користуватися довірою міжнародних партнерів.
Якщо це вдасться і незалежність Нацбанку не буде підірвано,
а поки гривню НБУ тримав стабільною.
Досить подивитися під час коронакризи, скільки валют
розвинених країн суттєво ослабли  -
Україна тут трималась дуже добре - як і в останні роки валюта була дуже стабільною.
Тому все залежить від того, щоб дати чіткі сигнали.
Курс реформ і незалежність Нацбанку поважають.
Якщо це буде так, то мій настрій оптимістичний.
Якщо ж будуть інші ознаки, то, звичайно, це відіб’ється і на фінансових ринках.
Експерти припускають, що як і у випадку з ексглавою НБУ Валерією Гонтарєвою,
політичний тиск на Нацбанк міг бути з боку певних олігархів -
зокрема, Ігоря Коломойського - та наближених до нього депутатів.
Однак могло тиснути і президентське оточення, яке, на думку оглядачів,
хотіло мати більш слухняного очільника НБУ,
оскільки саме від нього залежить друк додаткових грошей і кредитні ставки.
В офісі Зеленського наразі запевнили, що правління Нацбанку
свою роботу на принципах незалежності.
Утім, рік тому сам Зеленський якраз обіцяв захищати Смолія
і казав, що його контракт - на 7 років.